[Applause]
there are very few people who are used
to being seen by millions just a few
hours after giving birth now the Duchess
of Cambridge has spoken candidly on a
parenting podcast about the challenges
of being a mother in the public eye do
you struggle with mum girl yeah and you
know even this morning I went to the
nursery visit yeah mommy how could you
possibly not read or free off and
herself at school this morning but no
it's a constant talent the mother of
Prince George Princess Charlotte and
Prince Louis says raising three Royals
is not without its challenges even with
the extra help of a nanny so your port
north of sorts of directions yeah
because when the third comes like heart
you can you physically get all three
children out the car at the same time
you can't know that there's such a sort
of a pool but I'm such a hands-on mom
the Duchess also admits to not being the
happiest when pregnant after suffering
from severe morning sickness lots of
people have it far far worse but it was
definitely a challenge not just for me
but also for your loved ones around you
and I think that's the thing as being
pregnant could be a newborn baby and
things like that impacts everybody in in
the family you know when he didn't feel
he could do much to help and you know
it's hard for everyone to see you
suffering without actually do anything
about it this is Kate's first podcast
appearance but someone used to sharing
their parenting stories is mother of two
Kelly she's blogged about her journey
through motherhood for seven years and
finds aspects of the Cambridge's family
life relatable I certainly don't have
the Wardrobe that she has on my hair
said he was never in place like hers is
but she does have those instances in the
public eye where her children aren't
always behaving much like my own
children they're not always the quietest
when they want them to be and that's
just the way that children are since
joining the royal family the Duchess has
dedicated her time to focusing on early
years and championing children this
interview gives us a rare glimpse of
what goes into nurturing her family
never too far from judgment public
pressure and plenty of attention
a shahara nag Sky News